エリアに単体のハンターが出現。
賞金を手にするものは現れるのか?
ゲームが始まった。喉乾いたわね。
お、
かっこいいね。い、
これって期間限定のウィンターチョコスペシャルフラベジーノじゃないの?
すいません。
今カップルのラブラブドをチェックしていましてハグとかってできますか?
もちろんだよ。これ持って。[笑い]
あ、ありがとう。ありがとう。
こんなん余裕だよ。こんなんでいいかな。
見つかった。
あ、ちょっとやり。おいしい。
ブンブン。ハロー。YouTube。
どうもニセキです。
おお。2ないよ。ニ歌歌ってほしいよ。
いいよ。
YouTube
その近くに一体のハンター
主役は俺なのさ。へイ
見つかった。
終わり。終わり。開示だな。開始だな。
大事だよ、こんな。
どうやらここでは役のようだ。[笑い]
メールだ。
2を確保。残る逃走者は8名。
バイ。
ランフォマ逃走中バンカラジオスペシャル。今回の参加者は
9名。高劇の舞台は横浜港未来。
テーマパークや見晴しのいい公園がある広大なエリアだ。絶対逃げ切ります。だって僕天才ですから。
商品は1秒200円ずつ上昇。逃げ切れば
144万円。
賞金ゲットしたらブ解体です。
エリアにある自信用電話から電話すればその視点での賞金を獲得できる。ただしハンターに捕まれば即失格。賞金はゼル。
お、穴き、
おい、すくあの観覧者乗ろうぜ。
いいねえ。これって観覧って乗っていいの?
ルール的にはオです。でもさ、観覧者だったら下でハンター待ち伏せとかするんじゃない?
さすがに子供相手そんなせこいことしないっしょ。行こうぜ。
ないか。
無邪気な子供たちはまだ遊び盛かりだ。
あら、シだらけすか?お母さんじゃないの?
あら、北長きい子さんには。
汚いてて触いでもらえるかしら。
汚いものを触るにはちょうどいい手でしょ?
そうね。あんためっちゃ汚いからね。
うるさいわね。あなたの顔の方が汚いわよ。今すぐ潰してあげたいわ。
ゲームマスターは新たにミッションを発動。
今から15分後にハンター2
体を放出する。阻止するにはエリアに仕掛けられた
つのボタンを同時に押せ。ミッションハンター放出を蘇生よ。
ミッションに行くのは厳しそうだな。
おい、下にハンター待ち見せしてるぞ。あのスタッフ絶対ちっただろ。
おいらが行くしかねえな。おいらは行くぜ、どこまでも。
はい。
それじゃあボタンの前でまた会いましょう。
これは心理戦よ。私は行くつもりはないし。あの女も
行くわけないでしょ。ハンターなんて何人いたって一緒よ。
ミッションに行くかどうかは逃走者次第。こんじり好き。
よし、ここは3
人で力を合わせてミッションに行こう。
うん。
よし、みんなのとミッションの成功によって
え
おー。
シ、お前は俺についてこい。
はい。
先生かっこよくて見直しちゃった。
こっちだ。
はい。
お、
その近くに一体のハンター。
後ろからハンターだ。先に逃げろ。お年寄りやお子様連れの方は特にご注
見つかった。
ハンターだ。
線を内側に降りください。じじ倒した。
くそくそ。
騙されるが悪いんだ。
この男の事女に好感度という言葉はない。な
[笑い]
んで誰も来ないの?
俺のミッションはパチンコに勝って軽くぜ。落ちる人。
ミッション終了まで残り
30秒。
あ、もうダめだ。
間に合った。
ああ、す君。
あなく
ええ、
お前その顔やめろ。
数分前。
あなき、ここから飛び降りよう。
大丈夫?命のこうか?
違う。ここから飛び降りればミッションにも行けるしあのハンターも倒せるかもしれない。
どうやって飛び降りるんだよ。
この傘を使うんだ。
お前天才じゃかっこ。笑。あ、
大成功だ。
イエイ。運が味方しちゃね。
漏らしてんじゃねえか。う、く汚い。やめろ。
[笑い]
ハンターが戦闘不能になったためあなたに一体のハンターが放出された。
それじゃ行くよ。
ミッション成功。
ゲームマスターが新たにミッションを発動。
イエーイフ。イエイフ。
高島中央公園に賞金アップボタンを
つ設置した。そのボタンを押してる間は賞金単価が
1秒1000
円に跳ね上がる。ただしボタンを押している間は新たにハンター
5体が作動する。ミッション
賞金アップボタンを獲得せよ。早く回収しに行かないと取り返しのつかないことになるぞ。さてと一けしに行こうかしら。
パチンコで吸った分を倒れるバルしてやる。
お金が増えればみんなハッピーなんよ。
一体誰が賞金アップボタンを手にするのか。
最初に現れたのはシミエスカイウォーカーだ。
目標確保。大せなせ押せな押すな。押せな
のボタンが押
押しがった。
まだ
ハンターは来ないから安心しなさい。
どういうこと?
ボタンを押したら動く。ハンター
体は動けないように縛りつけております。
つまりボタンを押してもハンターの数は変わらないまま賞金だけアップするってわけ。
[音楽]
あら、あんた頭でかいから脳みそがたくさん詰まってるのね。歌
イ。みんなごめん。
そんなこと知らなくてハンターさんたち苦しそうだったから紐いちゃった
ねえ。大丈夫大丈夫。
[笑い]
よし。ありがてえ。
はあ。
見つかった。
リスク回避のためにボタンを破壊するわ。キャちポチっとな。
の
何してんだ?
狙われたのはな
んで全員私なの?あ、ちょっと待って、ちょっと待って。みんなさっきは助けてあげたでしょ?今度はみんなが私を助けてね。お願い。
ありがとう。
おい、おい、おい。
お前ら何やってんだ、お前、この野郎。追いかける。お前ら
行け。早く行け。お前ら
何やってんだ、あいつら。この野郎さ。
少女小学生じり自種します。コ
ジュリ成功。
ピコ様もっとボタンを押していただけないでしょうか。じゃあそこに止まってるハンター煽ってきなさい。かしこました。
え、お、え、お、自分の動けないのか、この人にが。え、お、え、悔しかったら動いてみろよ。
おとが詰めちゃったがれました。[笑い]
あのクソだめやがったらう、くそ。えー、えー、騙される方が悪いのよ。
教科書に乗せたいレベルの因が王方だ。
ハを確保。残る逃走者は
名。僕は緑だから芝の上にいればバレないんよ。お貴様ポカポカでうとうしてきたんよ。
え、うと言うとってことですか?
もーも
見つかった。
なんで何バれた?何?なんでな?なんでなんでバれた?けた。
うまくハンターを巻いたようだ。
アイスボールドの中だったら絶対バレないよ。
金のボタンが押されました。
誰かがお母さんの暴走を止めないと。
見つかった。
やばい。来た。
そこにもう1
人のハンター。絶対絶明。逃げきれるのか。
[笑い]
ターゲット補足。
この距離狙撃をしたら捕まるわ。
ボタンを壊して止まるハンターなら助かる。でもそれ以外ならこいつは縛った
5体のハンターの1
人ね。つまりボタンを破壊すれば止まる。
[笑い]
あ、あ、私のボタンがきっとしたことはこんなミスをするなんて。
ほの位置が違う双子ハンターだった。
メールだ。
指名スカを確保。また指名スカにより金のボタンを破壊された。
おかげで助かった。ゲームマスターは新たにミッションを発動。監視用ヘリコプターとロボット剣を放ったヘリとロボットに目撃された逃は一定時間ハンターに一情報が共有される。監視を逃れるためには
2ショット写真を撮れ。ミシ
監視の目から逃れろ。
おい、やれね。
お、わき、あのさ、写真なんだけど、バエスポットで撮ろうぜ。
バエスポット
いいから。
おい、なんでアンパンマンミュージアムの前なんだよ。だってあんな人アンパンマン好きでしょ?
俺はもう小賛だぜ。アンパンマンなんか見ねえよ。
じゃあこれは何?
あの、これは
イエーイ。
おい、あき消せ。頼むから消してくれ。やめろ、お前。
やちゃんに電話かけてみます。
お、お母さんから電話だ。
切っちゃえ、きっちゃえ。ならのそしたらゆうと君に電話かけます。もしもしゆと君。私とラブラブ通らない。
[笑い]
サブエだ。
誰が寒ですって。
寒いよ。
歌優言うと凍結。こちこちこちこちこちこち。
まあ、ヘリコプターなんてトンネルの中入ってれば問題ないしょ。
え、
ロバンコだ。逃げなきゃ。
お、
このわんこ、お金がついてるじゃないの?
10分前。
お、ロボット剣だ。
こいつは使えそうだな。
何やってんの?
お母さんはバカだから。ロボ犬にお金をつけたらこれを取りに来るはずだ。
バカって言ったってギャグマンガじゃないんだから。
ギャグマンガのバカだった。
あら、
おめキ子の位置情報がハンターに共有された。
あら、これこれない。あれ?あら、あ、何これ?
見つかった。これちょっとあんたじゃないの?
おい。ああ、
ちょっと待ちなさい。あたし。
私のお尻触ったわよね。時短金越しなさい。おキを確保。残る同者は
2名。よっしゃ、最後まで生き残るぞ。
ゲームマスターは新たにミッションを発動。ああ、あ、
メールだ。
日本メモリアルパークに武装したハンターを用意した。ハンターの背後にある
QRコードを読み取れば復活が
1枚手に入る。
ただし武装したハンターはボールを持っており、そのボールに当たったものは確保と見なされる。ミネシカードを獲得せよ。
アナキのお母さんのおかげで俺は助かった。俺は復活カードを取りに行く。
う、かっこいい。
お前も行くんだよ。おい、
かかってこいよ。お前小学生の頃ガ野の橋の方に向かってたタイプだろ。
お前のヘナチョコボールなんて当たんねえよ。え、こっちだよ。こっちだよ。
何すんだ?て
謝れよ。
あ、すいません。すいません。あの、今番組の撮影中でして、あの、
知らねえよ、そんなん。どしろよ。
すいませんでした。すいませんでした。すいませんでした。すいませんでした。すいませんでした。
お、復活ゲットだぜ。カップル撃大作戦大成功。
よっしゃ、行くぞ。
おい、おい、おい、おい、おい。お前どこやってんだよ、これ。
お前はふざけんじゃねえよ、お前。このコードこったよ。
その頃捕まった者たちは
よくも騙したな。
ピえピえピえ。
寒いよ。何をしてんの?
囚人服のお似合いね。
ん?あれも元も元FBIなのに牢獄。元
[笑い]
FBIなのに牢獄。何?
あやちゃんもちろん私のことを復活させてくれるわよね。いや、お母さんじゃなくてはい。
もらいます。復活私が使います。
おい、待って。あっていきこさん、それは
はな、何なのよ、あんた。ほら、やられちゃ、あんたも文句ないわよ。
いや、文句ある。はい。
あ、そう。
ありがとう。チャンネル。バイビ。
おい、
くっそ。
ちょっと変てね。お母さん、これで復活させてあげるよ。その代わり賞金半分ちょうだいね。
ナイスティールだわ。
行くぞ。
助けて助けて助けて助けて。
これを見ていたゲームマスターは[音楽]
このままだと逃走成功者が4
人も出てしまう。そうだ。この女を利用しよう。
新たにミッションを発動。
逃走者であるお神機構を逃走者全員で協力して捕まえろ。
確保に失敗した場合賞金はゼロとなる。
ミシおキ構を確保せよ。
まあ、とりあえず逃げればいいってことね。捕まえろったってどこにいるんだよ。
彼女につけていたGPS
で居場所を特定するわ。
あら、北長き子さん、こんにちは。
汚い手で触らないでもらえるかしら。バグ。
いや、これは
こんなに早く5険だったら最初か。
コラボ先のチャンネルでめたい発言は進みなさい。
こんなこと言ったってメタのもはまあまあまあまままま。
そこに忍びよる一体のハンター。
ここは私が引きつける。早く行きなさい。無茶だろ。
やめつけ。
超人なのはお前のお母さんだけじゃないぜ。後ろ橋すげえ。
お母さんの動きを止めないと。
お前す天才なんだろ。なんかねえの?
あ、
そうだ。ドーナ使ってくる。このタイミングで食ボキャラはきついって。
この列に並んでちゃ間に合わないな。
おい、
お前何やってんだ?
あ、僕金のボタンで動く反対だったからちょっと暇だなと思って。
お前この子と上にちったらどうなるか分かってるよな。
そ、それは勘弁してくれ。
じゃ、このドーナツもらわね。
お、ちょ、ちょっと。お、どうしよう。
お待たせ。
あ、よっしゃ、こうぜ。
バカ。
これでお母さんをおびき寄せるんだ。お母さんは流行りの甘いものが大好きなんだ。よし。
ええ、食いたかったのに。
こっちだ。
うわあ。これ私の食べたかった。アムどうなっじゃないの?お。
今だ。あ
ちまだいたのかよ。
うわあ。うわ。
ホログラム作戦大成功。
さすがだな。あき。うん。
確保。よっしゃ。
イエー。
屋根す穴きへ走成功。
やった。やったやったやったやったやった。イエーイ。
賞金はみんなでやけ。
あんたよくやったわね。
お母さんの期半分おれんだからな。
おい、お前ら。
窃盗剤頭法違反、オ物配隊でお前らを逮捕する。
ゲームが始まった。
ラブゲット。
新年はバンカラジオでライブ配信をします。
2026年もよろしく